survivor of an attack he says bad men
after him needs a place to hide we
figured he was just in shock so he gave
him a place to lie low we didn't
actually expect anyone to come after him
he's holed up at the abandoned gas
station up the hill you mean murder him
that's not our way even if Cobb is scum
he can bluster and threaten all he wants
hmm okay some of the others like Sonny
will probably stand up for Ringo if he
asked for personally I hope he sneaks
out of chain gangs real problem is it
turned was a big escape not too long ago
beak ok well let's guess that's so much
short answer chit your boy Connie I hear
how the [ __ ] tight uh yes Khan yeah yeah
anyway um we're gonna do that mission so
let's see what the details are here
offered out wearing a deal with the
powder gangers I like the show location
pretty close ok so let's do this how do
i sir quick save on
okay let's do it five bad thing supposed
to be just walking around and I'm
watching it okay where are you rang go
I've got my two cents just a deal with
your right now I used take that nothing
okay I know you're in there fetch that's
close enough who are you and what do you
want with me sorry about the gut we got
off to a bad start yeah he doesn't look
very tough though I'll have a much
bigger problem once his friends show up
yeah I'm gonna lay low for as long as I
can assuming all I've got left on me or
a handful of caps but you could okay
we just end up sharing the same group
start with Sonny smart ok ok hit just
blow that off right now I get the only
one to my right who's this nutjob what a
loser all right back there am I [ __ ]
away ok ok hello Cyril flight I place I
Jedi oh wait yeah he's [ __ ] fast
alone out of my way hi there sticking
around goods yeah say no more joe cobb
talks about leaving us alone if we hand
over Ringo but I know his type he
however between you me and ringo we
aren't too if you could convince Trudy
to join us I know easy Pete's got a
stock of dynamite somewhere finally
there's a good chance we'll all under
okay a silver tongue would help
convinced I don't even give is in
chatswood cabinet easy Pete's pretty
protective of his dynamite you'd have
I'm
okay Rango actually join us so you're
planning on taking on Jo Cobb's gang
it's a big rip all the more read okay so
it looks like they aren't gonna my
Christmas pretty much gone to [ __ ] so
I'm just going back to this dude we got
this is fight them you know we're just
gonna have to fight them I can handle
I'm I can handle bag flies on a day guys
good old fallout i love these missions
of games so [ __ ] big sounds as big as
me when they say good movie out hey
what's going on chinese what that well I
guess that meat that's Dennis all right
I'm ready time to look alive the powder
I'll be set up near the store that's
devis bechos way ho Oh anything haircut
tank no come on dad I says guys hold up
here scient hair this is what i am
talking about ok this is the stuff that
I know honey had where is he good that
[ __ ] I have a shock collar this gang
which whiskey this karma this game I am
[ __ ] beyond all recognition oh [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] did I take that what is that
yes I get let it cook save this [ __ ]
because that one's probably gonna die
it's ok
yes [ __ ] I'll dying you like that
alrighty sounds of [ __ ] die it's all
right now mm-hmm Cheyenne God guess at
God you know this is all gud such as
head yeah I like this hat i would take
this
[ __ ] what is that that's like this house
thank God God okay